we got one more story it's not a big
news story but I really want to talk
about it because it actually happened a
few years ago and it was it was kind of
like an exploitation of Vice and how
Vice turned from this like edgy punk
rock magazine into this ultra woke like
it is a complete inversion from where it
was you know so I have this story I'm
not gonna read it but I'm gonna show you
so that you you understand what I'm
talking about because I was having a
conversation with the production chimp
earlier about I'm I'm kidding but about
it's I'm gonna tell you guys the
reference the chimp is a reference to
the Joe Rogan podcast parody where Joe
Rogan has a chimp on as his guest I mean
and he's like I'm a big fan of your
working the champ just shrieks and then
he's like that's crazy and the trick the
chimp goes nuts that's the joke anyway
we were talking about how Vice had this
thing called a non-traditional work
place agreement and this is a story from
2017 Variety reported vice investigating
sexual harassment claims defends non
traditional workplace employment
contract this this contract was was
basically weaponized against vice and
I'm not I don't want to read the whole
thing but actually let me read a little
bit for a little a little bit for you
they say this it's a you know promotes
an environment environments of free
speech encourages employees to be
creative in all respects with respect to
the content of its magazine advertising
yadda yadda do the nature of their
business operations including but not
limited to you know there could be
sexually provocative other explicit
images videos and audio recordings are
regularly regularly present individuals
employed by Vice must be conscious of
vices non-traditional environment and
comfortable with exposure to and
participation in situations that may
present themselves during this course of
their employment while working advice I
acknowledge that I may be exposed to
highly provocative material some of it
containing extremely explicit sexual and
controversial content if I travel
off-site for project for projects and
perform work on locations I will be
confronted with unique and unusual
situations which may be considered
offensive indecent or unacceptable by
others so basically I'm pretty sure I
signed this agreement I'm pretty sure
they made me do it back when I joined I
mean
it makes sense but it feels like it's so
great like it could like anything could
have applied to that you know well
here's the problem and like it what's
what's it what's what's a good story I
mean remember when like who's at
celebrity she was getting out of the car
and like she wasn't weighing underwear
and a camera caught her at news beers
was it maybe I think or like Janet
Jackson and like Justin Timberlake
ripped off that was like 20 years ago by
the way but like he rips off her top or
whatever if you work in media this
completely makes sense yeah so what's
interesting to me is like if I'm talking
to somebody you know the news I do they
talk about Donald Trump you know let's
let's let's do style Trump as an example
they say the the leaked audio tape where
he said you know grab him by the [ __ ]
okay
can I not say that word would you know
if I'm in an office and someone says oh
I don't like you talking about those
things that sexually explicit but you're
actually quoting the president I mean
like it's news right you work for vice
yeah so here's what I here's what I'm
trying to say like I think one of the
things that destroyed vice and I've
talked to some of the former higher-ups
like why they went from being this dark
and edgy and fun yeah
- like morally outraged indignant
feminism really did change didn't it
totally changed so like here's the
example I gave everybody there's a there
was an article that was written that
said this horrifying app can show you
any woman's like you know breasts or
something something like that you can
google search it okay and I looked at
that now I was like you know what's
crazy in 2011 you're the title of that
article would have been hmm
this amazing app can show you any woman
topless right the tone was totally
flipped it used to be like we don't care
we skew the norms were edgy bad boys and
now it's like Oh Haram Phi say well I
never
why would they make such an app and I
was wondering why that happened I
started talking to somebody and we kind
of came up and it's this was weaponized
against voice basically saying it was
proof of how when the people advice they
really did get accused of like you know
me to hang some women and I'll tell you
this true that's the gray hair I was
talking about because it's the way this
is written it's not
it's almost like it's not necessarily
saying that it's gonna be you know the
content that they're gonna it's gonna be
the only it's not the content
I know exactly it's like it you know
it's like like when you go weird it's
it's a gray but look if you go to Japan
mm-hmm and they literally they did a doc
on this like five story sex shop yeah
well yeah it's not just the content it's
literally you're going to a sex shop
right so what ends up happening is they
said this is proof that like the people
advice thought they could do whatever
they wanted because they had agreements
signed but I think there's a clear
you know delineation between you are
working at a job that talks about and
explores these issues and some dude
assaulting you or or threatening your
job or something you know it's true so
what ends up happening is they do this
because it makes sense like come on man
if I'm gonna if we're literally talking
about this subject and I'm saying the
word sex and talking about Trump yeah
what happens if someone I hire says I
don't like it when you use the word
[ __ ] can you not say that because it's
like it makes me uncomfortable yeah and
as a woman and then I've been warned and
then what I get sued for sexual
harassment for talking about genitals
but it's we're actually reporting the
news right so it's like what would
happen if you know I don't have you
heard the story but one of the there's
an executive at Netflix okay who was
explaining to people racial slurs oh
yeah I heard about that get fired
because he explained that the n-word was
offensive or you know I will never eat
Papa John's yes you know why why they
fired John Schnatter Papa John himself
because on a phone call he said why is
it that you know Colonel Sanders can say
the n-word but he actually said the
n-word and like nobody says anything but
you know now everyone's freaked out he
was basically complaining as a double
standard yeah and somebody on the call
was like aha he's had the word and they
they removed the guy from everything
that's good I'm like that's crazy
look I'm not I'm not saying I'm a fan of
Papa John's or the guy I'm just like
that's crazy
yeah that's a little too much I'm you
know I got to be honest I'll probably
Papa John's I really don't care yeah
that's just people going nuts for no
reason just because they
think someone else is gonna be offended
leverage but so I want to talk about
this cuz I'm like what am I supposed to
do I can't have this agreement vise so
here's basically what here's what I
wanted you know to bring up I think this
is exactly what caused Vice or one of
the moments that caused it to flip and
become something completely different
from when I worked there you know like I
when I joined it was actually at this
transitional period where people stopped
like they were there actually getting
rid of the old-school punk rock people
who got paid dirt and bringing on real
traditional like corporate you know
employees I remember that was like you
know I'm not gonna name anybody there
was one person it was very obviously
just in the job because they had always
had the job like when vice was very
scrappy they brought it whoever was
willing to do a certain job you know ten
years later they're like we can afford
to hire a legit corporate you know
person yeah and so they would do this
but they had always been they were it
was been accused of being a boys club
and then once the assault start getting
reported and I'll say this too like my
understanding is I heard all these
stories too and some of these people I
know and I trust and I believe I mean
you know bison you work for vice while
back you know was it a boys club
you were you were kind of you were
working there almost it feels like
during the transition - right you know
the newer vice that's one of it's one of
it well yes it was it was like you know
just around the time I had joined Shane
the CEO would literally sit in the same
room as everybody else mocha but around
the time like within those next few
weeks he was like on flights he was
never around then they built him he
built a private office that he was in
doors closed and now he was like you
know it used to be you'd walk in and
you'd see the the c-suite guys sitting
in the same room as everybody else is
this when they were in Williamsburg yeah
right I mean I think they still
technically are probably they moved to a
new building though but so I was talking
to somebody I'm really I'm really hoping
they would come on you know the show and
we could do a big long thing about the
media mm-hmm it's a friend of mine who
was like relatively high up telling me
that with things like this is this non
traditional workplace agreement with the
accusations against some of these
employees which you know I'll say this
too like these assault claims that I
personally believe them you know
not all of necessarily but I know some
of them I've I know some of these people
and I trust them so this created a
investor pressure and what I was told
was that for vice they had this moment
where the investors came in and said I
don't know but all at the same time but
like the Avengers basically said listen
you are being accused by all of these
women of doing these things we don't
want to lose our investment the only way
out of this is if vice embraces locusts
or feminism because then we can say it's
not a boys club look we're all about you
know protecting women and marginalized
people's and so because of the investors
the people advice were like okay okay
we'll do it and all of a sudden you have
a company that men you know I'll tell
you what it's mind-blowing to me to see
the people at vice news today versus the
people when I was there so I was the
first vice news person and Shane's words
it was because of me they decided to
create vice news as it is today as an
actual field reporting his thing there's
a complicated history that I probably
don't know a lot about I know that they
wanted to do some kind of channel for
Vice news that was basically I probably
shouldn't say too much because I don't
want to infringe on anybody's privacy
rights or anything but the iteration
where they went on the ground reporting
what they do today
yeah was me and so the HBO show they're
not the vice news HBO show not the vice
one that one preceded me
yeah yeah so vice on HBO was different
was a news magazine so so here's
actually a really good point
the original vice show which is now on
Showtime I guess is not news relevant
that was the point there was so
initially the idea was like we'll go
interview a guy who makes bulletproof
clothing has nothing to do with politics
it was an interesting news story right
when they would do stories that were
relevant to the news cycle like protests
in Spain or something mm-hmm they would
brand it vice news but it wasn't an
official vertical you know I mean yeah
and so it wasn't something actually
cared to do okay I actually I didn't ago
she ate them for a long time to convince
them and then under vice.com I went to
Venezuela I went to Ukraine I went to
Brazil and actually did field reporting
and Turkey and then from there they were
like okay we're
launched a new channel specifically for
this kind of news reporting yeah the
people we brought on we're like legit
reporters and they had you signed this
that back then I'm pretty sure I did
sign this how long do you think they've
been doing this like from the get-go
when the get-go
wellmaybe necessarily but it got to a
point man I left I was there for just
over a year close to a year and a half I
left and I joined fusion which yeah it's
a weird a weird thing happened and it
was a big mistake when I joined so I was
at vice and for the most part it was you
know kind of straight like nobody told
me what I could or couldn't do for the
most part I mean for the most part like
obviously I was like hey I'm gonna go
fly to Antarctica they're like we
talking about yeah but it's like hey
here's a big thing here's my raisin they
say great you're good to go yeah and so
by the time I was leaving I could feel
it becoming more and more corporate and
so I was like you know what man I'm
gonna sit here the pay is not that great
I'm not one of these cultists you know I
mean there's a lot of people who are all
about just being advice no matter what
I'm cool I work right and so in
Williamsburg right and I'm like dude you
make thirty thousand a year don't spend
a thousand bucks a month on right where
you nuts
yeah and those but I want to live in we
can go to the bar and then complain
about how I can't afford to travel the
world to be a journalist don't want to
hear it yeah so I ended up getting an
offer from the Disney Company
it was the ABC Univision company fusion
yeah and they told me what you're doing
with vice knows is epic we want to do
that here too and I said great here's
what I want I want to budget I want to
staff they gave me everything right
mm-hmm
six months later they said we've decided
to go completely woke you know feminist
far-left and I'm just like I why and so
that was when you were trying to do this
show right well it was a I was like
that's right after that like no no it
was like a year it was a year later yes
I moved to Miami right then you came
down mm-hmm yeah so Adam ends up moving
you down to Miami with me and we're all
trying to figure how we can do something
like this
now I have more capability to do it you
know my own company things are going
well we expanded this you know the space
here we are and I got to be honest too
like I have no idea what we're doing you
know what it's fun to talk randomly
yesterday we were talking about
youtubers are the moderators having to
sign that thing for
PTSD right and I figured like I don't
see PTSD in here but I feel like this
would be you know it should be included
in that also like there you know you
know basically what it's saying is
here's here's the main point I want to
bring up with this non-traditional work
place agreement let me let me let me
show everyone just again so you know for
those that are just tuning in you might
see what we're actually talking about it
is a single-page contract it says I have
voluntarily accepted my employment with
Vice I agree to hold vais harmless from
any and all claims I may have based upon
vises workplace environment or my
exposure to specific text images or
information in the course of my
employment with Vice if at any time in
the future I believe that the workplace
environment advice has become offensive
I will inform Human Resources
immediately so here's the thing we're in
this we're in this world now where
nobody wants to deal with the PR issue
so something weird happened when I was
going to work for fusion they said like
one of their flagship show was called
drug wars and it was like tracking
military efforts against the cartels
yeah very much like vice number them and
it was that it was always their biggest
show mm-hmm I joined them I say here's
what we're gonna do we started doing it
and then for some reason six months
later they were like we've decided we're
a progressive company they used to have
posters on the wall that said we will
not be partisan you know we're not left
we're not right and all of a sudden now
that all changed you know well guess
what happens when you come to me and say
hey Tim by the way we want you to push
this not gonna exactly is it true is it
true good yeah yeah right it's not sorry
yeah so eventually I end up in a house
in Miami with you and we're sitting
there like what should we do I do the
vitals they don't want me to do work
because you know it was really funny I'd
pitch stuff they'd be like well yeah I
remember that's the about trans kids
that's what they said to us when we were
sitting there and right meeting with
them oh man yeah we met the oh right
that's right they're talking about doing
the show yeah he was that he was about
it yeah and then that was it
yep I was like all right